Exclusive new
reporting this
morning about China's air ship program.
We have never before
seen photos
obtained by CNN
of a Chinese military blimp
was caught on satellite
in a remote desert base
in northwestern China.
You can see it right there.
These pictures are from November 2022,
which is three months
before a Chinese spy
Blue was shot down off the coast
of South Carolina.
CNN's Alex Marquardt joins us now.
Alex, you're part of the reporting team
that's broke
broke this story about this balloon
What are we looking at?
Why is this important?
Yeah, John,
my colleague
Paul Murphy
and I obtained these images
from a satellite imagery
company called Black Sky.
And what they show
is what we believe
to be
some part of the Chinese military arsenal
that has never been seen before.
These images taken at a base in the
in an area called Corolla
in northwestern China.
It is a remote desert base
that is associated
with the Chinese military. The play.
This is an area
that has been studied for years.
We've seen other satellite imagery
of that base.
But what we've never seen before
is a blimp
that is associated
with the Chinese military
it is on that long runway
that is about 3300 feet long.
The blimp itself is about 100 feet
or 30 meters long.
It's just outside a huge hangar.
And what this indicates, John,
what experts tell us is an advancement
in the Chinese airship military program,
that it's getting more sophisticated.
Of course,
we've known for quite some time
that they do have an airship program.
Americans know all too
well that they've been using Chinese
spy balloons.
We saw back in January, February
that spy balloon across the country.
But a blimp is a lot
more sophisticated, it's
more maneuverable,
it's more nav of a navigable
as one expert.
But one expert
we spoke with
likened it to a submarine in the skies,
which has its own,
we believe, a propulsion
and navigation system.
And what this blimp would do
is carry out
what's called ISR,
intelligence, surveillance
and reconnaissance.
So it really does represent,
according to a number of experts
we spoke with,
a real progress in their airship program
that they are doing
a lot more to advance it.
Now, blimps
would be a lot more advantageous
on a number of levels
that are a lot cheaper
than planes and satellites
that would carry out ISR.
They can stay in the air
a lot longer than planes, of course.
And John,
what's really interesting is also
what's around this blimp.
There's that huge hangar,
that very long runway.
And people
we speak to say that
that could be an indication
that they're actually building
a much bigger
and more sophisticated airship.
There's a lot of construction
going on around there.
So experts
certainly keeping a close eye on this.
I did reach out to
the Biden administration,
the CIA declined to comment.
The National Security Council
did not comment.
But I did speak to a senior
defense official
who said that
if it's visible from the sky,
you can be sure that we're tracking it.
John, yet
these pictures very revealing,
very interesting.
One defense expert
I spoke with the last few weeks
basically said
the Chinese have found a way
to exploit
Western defenses
with the use of these airships.
Alex Marquardt, terrific reporting.
Thank you.